sun sand and selfies this is how Italy's
Deputy Prime Minister has become the
country's most popular politician he's a
leader who rarely misses a photo
opportunity or a chance to get close to
the voters salvini spent this weekend
literally pressing the flesh in southern
Italy
he seems like a politician who's close
to the people he's come here to meet us
amongst the hidden treasures of the
South but salvini was in the South for
more than just the beautiful beaches the
south is where Italy's immigration
debate is most raw it's here that
hundreds of thousands of migrants have
come ashore in the last five years the
Interior Minister has used his tough
stance on immigration to turn his Liga
from a regional party into Italy's most
popular political force I've just been
to NGO boats carrying hundreds of
migrants from entering people are
protesting but who cares still
controversy dog salvini wherever he goes
left-wing protestors even followed him
to the beach his populist
anti-immigration rhetoric has divided
the country in Sicily supporters and
opponents broad as salvini meda city
mayor and many were afraid of what would
happen if he became prime minister
if Savini gets an absolute majority it
will have terrible consequences for the
country
Cellini isn't merely a voice in favor of
Italian sovereignty he's quite close to
being a racist or a xenophobe whether
the interior minister heads up a new
government depends on whether there are
new elections
right now it's unclear if the Liga has
enough votes in Parliament to force them
through but if there is an election
Matteo salvini looks set to win that
would have immense consequences for
Italy and the AU all right well let's
bring in our correspondent band Leggett
he's been following this story for us
from Brussels high-band so how is this
going to pan out how likely is it that
Matteo salvinia will get his way on this
no confidence vote there will be snap
elections in Italy at some point in time
but maybe not so fast as the right-wing
leader Matt here Savini wants them
because there are many hurdles to this
step to take for example there is the
possibility that the left-wing populist
s' king cristela 5 stars and the current
opposition the Socialists team up and
form a new majority to keep the current
prime minister
Josep acanti in power there's also the
possibility that charge you're
mattarella the president of the state
chooses to install a caretaker
government and leave parliament in place
that could he can do that for up to one
year and there's of course also the
possibility that the Senate which is
deliberating as we speak with block or
stall the appeal by Matias Aviv for a
vote of no-confidence so many entangle
things like a big bowl of spaghetti
there's many options still that it has
also show at the end there will be some
elections maybe at the end of the year
and what consequences could all of this
have for Europe well a crisis Italy of
course it's always bad news for Europe
because the Italian economy is weak and
the government is obliged to table a
budget for the next year which it will
not do in this crisis situation and
there's no plan how to get rid of the
overwhelmingly high debt in Italy and
that also talked that Matteo salvini as
a prime minister could leave the Euro
the
common currency he denies that but still
there are these rumors and this would be
of course a major crisis for the
European Union and also the first stress
test for also laFonda line the further
the new incoming EU Commission president
all right DW van Riga reporting there
for us from Brussels Thank You band a
row the face of a high-speed train line
between the cities of Turin and Leon
could be the issue that leads to the
collapse of Italy's fragile coalition
government the country's five star
movement wants to scrap the project but
coalition partners the league headed by
interior minister Matteo salvini are
determined for it to go ahead when the
country's populist government came to
power 14 months ago at pledge to
kick-start growth but instead of a
promised boom the Italian economy has
contracted by 0.2% this year national
debt currently at 132 percent of the
country's entire economic output is more
than twice of what EU rules allow and
that figure is expected to rise by a
further two percent relations between
Italy and the EU are already strained
now there are fears that the country's
political turmoil could deal a further
blow to already sluggish eurozone growth
all right let's talk some more about the
crisis in Italy with Marcus Ville senior
economist at the University of San
Callan and Switzerland Marcus good to
have you on the program
mr. Cellini is pushing for a
no-confidence vote in the Italian
Parliament this week he aims to become
Prime Minister's chances aren't that bad
his party's pulling way ahead of all the
others would this be good news or bad
news for Italy and for Europe no the
beach boy wouldn't be good news neither
for Italy nor for Europe I mean mrs.
Cellini is a populist he's arguing with
migration policy figures and discussions
and he hasn't reflected at all on the
economic situation of Italy now let's
take a look at the economic situation
here the government that mr. Savini was
a big part of under this government
unemployment dropped slightly Italy
increased its exports has a trade
balance of 46 billion euros it doesn't
seem to be that bad does it it's not a
bad country at all I mean Italy is 34
largest economy in the eurozone
it's I think and I'm gonna eight or nine
in the world so it's it's it's a country
with luxottica was DeLonghi with Ferrari
with say looks and many other
corporations particularly in the
northern Italy region which are very
good so the country is is has it has a
very good basis for for an economic
performance but on the other hand I mean
the debt figures and the bureaucracy and
the politics is the bad side of Italy
and that hasn't changed under the the
government which is now on the brink of
collapsing Italy is due to start
preparations for its 2020 budget in
September now if we look back at this
year's budget that has already been
content it was it was a contagious
budget it was highly debated in in in
Brussels what do we make of these prep
negotiations ahead of us now well if
mrs. salvini really would become Prime
Minister the budget process and the
discussions with Brussels will be very
very difficult too no doubt about it and
whether or not he will become Prime
Minister is it remains to be seen but I
mean if you would have a budget surplus
or deficit of two pointers one or two or
three
and isn't really the issue because we
need to actually get down from the 135
GDP to debt ratio which amounted in
Italy over the years and you need
structural reforms for that you need
infrastructure reforms for that you need
a cut in in pensions you need tax
reforms and so forth and none of this is
really something what missus Lavinia
would want to do he has told the people
completely different story Marcus will
senior economist of the University of
San Galan talking to us about the
situation in Italy Marcus thanks for
being on the show welcome